[Musique]
ce devait être un ciel sans nuage
un horizon dégagé aéroports de paris
propriété de l'état français et leader
mondial du secteur adp devait être
privatisée c'était inscrit dans la loi
pacte et à l'assemblée tout se déroulait
comme à l'accoutumée la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre le premier
ministre était monté lui-même au créneau
dans la façon dont fonctionne
aujourd'hui aéroports de paris est
largement perfectible
nous savons que la qualité de service le
montant des investissements ne sont pas
aujourd'hui satisfaisant l'opposition
avait bien élever la voix
vous êtes en train de commettre une
erreur irréparable
c'est aussi une erreur en ce sens que
c'est quand même orly roissy additionnez
100 millions de passagers c'est la
première frontière de france et
privatiser une frontière
c'est une faute et un abandon de
souveraineté nationale mais à la fin
l'écrasante majorité des députés en
marche avait balayé les objections pour
42 contre eux 17
l'assemblée nationale a adopté l'article
l'histoire aurait dû s'arrêter là
pourtant un an et demi plus tard rien
n'a bougé
aéroports de paris est toujours dans le
giron de l'état et cela n'est pas près
de changer
une demande de référendum est un virus
ont modifié le plan de vol
tout a commencé lors du débat sur la loi
pacte la privatisation des aéroports de
paris déclenche alors quelque chose de
rare dans l'hémicycle on a tous les
arguments on privatise pas nos
frontières c'est pas le marché qui doit
dicter sa loi les actionnaires c'est un
mais c'est une mauvaise affaire
financière
il y a une forme de convergence des
oppositions autour d'un sujet qui leur
paraît être un sujet d'intérêt national
l'intérêt supérieur j'ai échangé avec ma
collègue lr marie christine dalloz
ma voisine avec valérie rabault que je
voyais régulièrement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
cette question les sénateurs cela pose
aussi car l'examen du texte chez eux a
produit les mêmes effets
quand nous avons vu cette majorité
improbable inédite au sénat entre heller
le pc le ps quelques radicaux qui
étaient là on s'est dit mais il ya un
coup à jouer on se rend compte que il ya
peut-être la possibilité de réunir les
185 signature nécessaire un référendum
d'initiative partagée est ribes et trois
lettres pour référendum d'initiative
partagée une idée du président nicolas
sarkozy en 2008
pour redonner du pouvoir aux citoyens
comment le peuple souverain peut-il
prolonger sa confiance renouvelé sa
confiance ou retirer sa confiance
voilà en vérité la question centrale de
la réforme des institutions de la
république
cette nouvelle forme de référendum est
alors gravé dans l'article 11 de la
constitution
mais depuis toutes les tentatives de
ripon échoué les parlementaires vont
vite comprendre pourquoi car le rip
c'est un peu comme un labyrinthe dans un
jeu vidéo pour progresser dans le
labyrinthe il faut d'abord franchir les
portes du parlement puis celle du
conseil constitutionnel pour pouvoir
ensuite se présenter devant les français
ce n'est qu'au terme de cette course
d'obstacles que le référendum peut être
organisée à un parcours du combattant
[Musique]
pour ce premier niveau députés et
sénateurs ne peuvent compter que sur eux
tout se joue donc dans l'enceinte du
parlement
la mission consiste à rassembler 20 %
des parlementaires pour porter une
demande de référendum
ce sont les socialistes qui vont donner
le coup d'envoi
valérie rabault va s'en charger à
l'assemblée nationale la présidente du
groupe ps a fait les comptes
elle sait qu'il faudra lire une partie
de la droite elle peut compter sur le
soutien de gilles carez figure respectée
et écoutée des républicains il décide
d'en parler à la réunion de son groupe
christian jacob dit bon tu n'auras pas
le soutien du groupe en tant
qu'institution mais si tu veux essayer
de réunir des signatures
bah ça ne pose pas de problème donc j'ai
eu carte blanche quelque sorte pour
mobiliser mes collègues
au sénat aussi la chasse aux signatures
est lancé j'ai signé ou 150 lettres
individuellement avec un petit mot à
chacun est donc là il a fallu aller
chercher y compris des signatures de
deux sénateurs qui étaient partis donc
il a fallu qu'ils nous les envoient par
chronopost enfin c'était tout un cirque
comme témoin l'expression une
mobilisation qui va payer
à l'assemblée la moitié des républicains
toute la gauche et une partie des
centristes vont signer en quelques jours
le compte y est
le 9 avril les journalistes sont
convoqués et comme le voulaient les
conspirateurs
la majorité n'a rien vu venir alors au
sein de l'assemblée dans cet espace
appelé les quatre colonnes c'est la très
précisément grâce aux médias que j'ai
découvert cette procédure ce procédé mis
en place par une conjonction
d'opposition
l'opposition s'apprête donc à annoncer
sa première victoire dans la course au
rip
tout est prêt pour offrir à la presse
l'image d'une alliance inédite victoire
facile sans doute un peu trop
un grain de sable va venir enrayer la
machine à l'épée arabo envoie un texto
lui demandant de la rappelé en urgence
et à la paix pas le pépin c'est que les
républicains bloquent sur la présence de
la france insoumise parmi les
signataires au point que le groupe de
jean luc mélenchon a été tenu à l'écart
de l'opération médiatique le jour j là
j'apprends tout d'un coup que il ya une
conférence de presse prévue pour
annoncer ce dépôt de propositions de loi
déjà ça m'étonne et puis après j'entends
des journalistes qui me disent il paraît
que vous signez pas ça m'étonne
doublement moi je n'ai entendu parler de
l'efi que
quelques heures avant la conférence de
presse ils sont comme les coucous il se
met dans tous les nids où on peut voilà
on peut les voir se mettre en évidence
des noms d'oiseaux qui traduisent de
très vives tensions
pendant que les journalistes attendent
une réunion de crise se tient à deux pas
de là entre valérie rabault et la france
insoumis
tout cela discute en disant nous si on
veut en être et si vous ne nous accepter
pas on le fera savoir
je crois que c'est un peu comme ça que
ça que ça se joue alors valérie m'a
appelé pour me dire mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait est ce que il faut pas annulé la
conférence presse je dis bien sûr non on
va pas on va pas l'annuler si eric
coquerel venir il viendra et puis
prendra la parole
voilà bon merci beaucoup d'être venus
aussi nombreuses et et aussi nombreux
pour assister à cette conférence de
presse à ce stade il faut donc 185
signature nous sommes bien au delà il ya
à ce moment où je vous parle
197 signature sans doute d'autres se
joindront à la démarche je ne sais pas
qui s'est entendu avec qui donc quand je
présente la démarche jeudi lesquels des
signatures sont acquises
et puis je laisse la porte une certaine
manière ouverte à d'autres signatures
une porte ouverte dans laquelle eric
coquerel s'engouffre sans hésiter bien
évidemment le groupe france insoumise
signe ses produits son lad référendaire
on a eu des petits problèmes
administratifs mais c'est peut-être
parce que
l'excusé fait sourire les participants à
cet instant la france insoumise rejoint
officiellement l'alliance des
oppositions
[Musique]
la première chose que je me dis c'est
d'abord mon étonnement un étonnant
quasiment physique de voir gilles carez
aux côtés de député communiste
révolutionnaire de voir ce que certains
ont appelé une alliance baroque ou de
circonstance qui n'avait en réalité
qu'un seul point commun s'opposer en
s'alliant à la gauche les républicains
risque-t-il leur réputation
c'est précisément sur ce point que bruno
le maire les attaques
mesdames et messieurs les républicains
sa vue vous faire bizarre d'avoir comme
porte-parole de votre opposition à la
privatisation d'atp le porte parole de
groupe du parti socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale
vous avez dû vous demander mais est ce
que je me suis pas trompé de salle
vous ne savez plus on vous habitez vous
n'avez plus pouvait le nord ou le sud où
elle est onewest
je savais qu'au ministre bon utiliserait
cet argument mais entre nous bruno le
maire qui parle d'attelage baroque
c'est un peu pour moi l'hôpital qui se
moque de la charité
nous on a peut-être un attelage un peu
surprenant sur un sujet bruno le maire
c'est plutôt bon structurelles je dirais
c'est donc sans complexe et plutôt unis
que l'attelage baroque réussi sa
première mission les coups fourrés en
politique il faut toujours se dire que
c'est possible
et là je dois dire que l'opposition a
bien joué elle a joué son jeu elle a
bien joué et donc il faut toujours
anticiper ce genre de process à peine le
premier obstacle franchi
voici que se profile le deuxième le
conseil constitutionnel son rôle
vérifier que la procédure respecte ce
que prévoit la constitution
il faut donc obtenir son feu vert pour
que l' aventure du rip continue
l'article 11 a placé sur la route des
parlementaires un obstacle de taille
c'est écrit noir sur blanc la demande de
rip ne peut pas concerner une loi
promulguée depuis moins d'un an
en clair le législateur ne veux pas
qu'on s'attaque à des lois trop récente
les parlementaires qui avaient bien lu
leurs articles 11 ont alors trouvé un
subterfuge
donc pour nous la coupe de la monde
c'était absolument de que le rythme soit
enclenché déposé sur le bureau du
conseil constitutionnel non seulement
avant la promulgation du texte pacte
mais avant même son vote définitif à
l'assemblée nationale
la ruse la voici à l'assemblée une loi
est d'abord examiné puis votée avant
d'être promulgué par le président de la
république les parlementaires ont pris
soin de demander le rip
avant promulgation ainsi la loi pacte
n'est pas promulguée depuis moins d'un
an puisqu'elle n'est même pas encore
votée l'opposition tente le coup nous
sommes dans les clous juridique puisque
on n'a pas le droit de soumettre à cette
procédure de référendum article 11 des
dispositions législatives qui ont été
adoptés depuis - moins d'un an
bon là ça n'est pas adopté on est des
juste à la limite
le conseil constitutionnel va-t-il
suivre une opposition qui joue sur les
mots
il a un mois pour trancher le 9 mai la
décision est brandi comme un trophée
salle des quatre colonnes le conseil
constitutionnel a donné son feu vert à
la demande de référendum devant les
caméras l'opposition se congratule
merci beaucoup merci les nouvelles et la
complicité comme de la commission des
finances
on a toujours su travailler ensemble
erreur
ce que viennent d'obtenir les députés et
son précédent le peuple peut remettre en
cause une loi tant qu'elle n'a pas été
promulguée pour la majorité c'est une
décision lourde de conséquences qui
fragilise le parlement moi je regrette
je l'avais fait à la tribune je le fais
encore aujourd'hui que des
parlementaires d'une certaine manière
scie la branche sur laquelle ils sont
assis en utilisant à trou de souris
juridique pour mettre en concurrence la
démocratie parlementaire et la
démocratie directe il décrédibilise le
travail parlementaire et oui ils font le
jeu des populismes une fois encore je ne
crains pas le peuple français au
contraire je crains de populisme je
pense que la démocratie
depuis que je suis élu je la vois vivre
au sein du parlement elle est
extrêmement fragile et l'anti
parlementarisme que nous vivons que je
vis au quotidien dans ma permanence sur
les marchés sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est une plaie c'est pas une plaie
spécifiquement pour la république en
marche c'est une plaie pour la
république française pour le parti
socialiste pour les l ère pour l efi
pour tout le monde et je pense qu'il
faut faire attention quand on verse de
l'eau à un moulin à faire en sorte que
le moulin à un moment ne se retourne pas
contre vous le sentiment qui est le mien
dans l'élection de l'exécutif c'est qu'
il est très contrarié il est très
contrarié et il en tirer les mauvaises
conclusions qui considère qu' on porte
atteinte à la démocratie représentative
alors que ce référendum d'initiative
partagée procède de la démocratie
représentative
ce n'est pas une initiative citoyenne
c'est une initiative parlementaire
ça va
c'est un beau succès c'était du travail
il fallait convaincre
l'alliance du rip a franchi le deuxième
obstacle laventure peut continuer il ya
une deuxième phase qui s'enclenche et là
nous donnons les clés pour cette
deuxième phase à nos concitoyens en leur
disant vous avez la possibilité c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
république que vous avez la possibilité
qui vous est donnée par une démarche des
parlementaires de dire de vous exprimer
de dire que vous ne voulez pas la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris
[Musique]
l'obstacle du conseil constitutionnel
est franchie les parlementaires vont
pouvoir présenter leur demande de
référendum aux français pour ce
troisième niveau
le défi est énorme il faut obtenir le
soutien de 10% des électeurs soit 4
millions 700 mille français en à peine
neuf mois
pour recueillir les signatures un seul
site celui ci les français munis de leur
carte d'identité peuvent signer une
pétition pour demander le référendum
le site est géré par le ministère de
l'intérieur sous le contrôle du conseil
constitutionnel du très sérieux donc
sauf que les premières heures sont
catastrophiques
les messages d'erreur se multiplient les
internautes en colère se plaignent la
france insoumise sont fait l'écho dans
l'hémicycle
nous avons reçu la 2 153 messages de
personnes qui arrivent pas à signer en
ce moment sur le site du gouvernement
on reçoit des messages sur erreur 404
page note fund königssee non postale
comme une absente deux fois que j'essaye
et samedi forbidden you don't have
permission to access on nous avait dit
que c'était la start-up nacion ya deux
hypothèses la première hypothèse
c'est une hypothèse d' incompétence ou
sinon c'est qu'il ya de la mauvaise
volonté
pendant que françois ruffin alerte
l'hémicycle les vacances son collègue de
la france insoumise eric coquerel
traverse la scène direction le ministère
de l'intérieur de ce que je comprends de
ce matin ebook d'un peu partout et je
crois pas que ça soit involontaire pense
qu'ils vont nous mettre des bâtons dans
les roues en permanence sur place
eric coquerel retrouve ses collègues de
rip toujours pas à moi j'ai pas réussi
j'ai pas réussi là cinq minutes chacun a
constaté les bugs du site internet
christophe castaner va devoir
s'expliquer
[Musique]
il faut noter la forme 2d coûte réel du
ministre de l'intérieur jean plus
souligné les difficultés déjà repéré
dans le lancement du site internet
nous avons eu des réponses donc
maintenant nous serons extrêmement
vigilants naturellement sur le bon suivi
de cette procédure
ils vont appliquer la loi et rien que la
loi c'est à dire que malheureusement ce
qui ce qu'on pourrait attendre par
exemple en terme de campagne
audiovisuelle même neutre pour informer
les français je crains que le
gouvernement n'aille pas plus loin que
ce à quoi la loi langage c'est donc seul
que les parlementaires vont devoir mener
cette campagne est il la prépare déjà la
queue pour jeudi à sahm n'est là on
pourra peut-être leur donner 5 minutes
deux minutes l'appareil en a deux le
premier grand meeting se profile le défi
réunir droite et gauche dans la même
salle
ils viennent et on alors dans leur dit
fatton testing rayon scénario la france
a tous la même estrade jeudi à saint
denis vous êtes cordialement invités
les français vont-ils accepter ce
mariage entre la droite et la gauche
en guise de test les signataires du rip
ont choisi à un bastion communiste saint
denis
aujourd'hui c'est un exercice de
pédagogie c'est un coup de départ c'est
quand vous vous tous et surtout aux
joueurs avant de plonger
ben voilà on donne ce coup de talon
[Musique]
décidément c'est parlementaires là ne se
quittent plus la fine équipe se répartit
le temps de parole est toujours flou
causé le seul qui intervient en amont
laisse aussi un peu de place à ceux qui
vont résulter possède une vidéo moi g
cette union
tout est prêt jusqu'au message d'accueil
en forme de clin d'oeil
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
à bord du vol 93 de son à destination de
4,7 millions de signatures pour un
référendum a ajouté cette île partagée
contre la privatisation d'aéroports de
paris
nous sommes dans une réunion peu banal
disons le donc la première chose que
j'ai envie de vous demander c'est que
tous ses parlementaires de droite comme
de gauche on peut les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
stéphane peu c'est à qui il s'adresse
dans la salle quelques syndicalistes de
la cgt et de nombreux militants
communistes
quel accueil vont ils réservés aux élus
de droite gilles carez qui est ici il
est un homme de droite qui fait des
choix d'homme de droite n'ont peut être
de droite et faire parfois aussi preuve
d'intelligence c'est pas interdit
la blague permet de détendre
l'atmosphère à gilles carez maintenant
de transformer l'essai j'étais choquée
lors d'une réponse du premier ministre à
l'assemblée sur le thème qui veut tuer
son chien l'accuse de la rage
on nous disait mais adp mal géré mais là
je voudrais rendre hommage au personnel
d'adp et paix parce qu'à des pets une
entreprise bien gérée
c'est une entreprise performante
à l'applaudimètre
gilles carez s'impose haut la main mais
plutôt de droite de gauche de gauche où
il avoue vous applaudissez gilles carez
députés de droite vous fait lorsque
c'est un homme intègre très intelligent
et je pense qu elle toujours une
certaine droiture ces communistes
même si on n'a pas les mêmes idées il
faut combattre en sont les choses qui
nous importe
ce soir là une semaine après l'ouverture
du site
deux cent mille signatures ont déjà été
enregistrés mais il en manque encore
quatre millions et demi le bout du
labyrinthe est encore loin chacun va
actionner ses réseaux les réseaux
familiaux les réseaux amicaux les
réseaux politiques les réseaux
associatifs pour obtenir les 4 millions
700 mille signatures va falloir faire
des tables commune il falloir aller avec
nos petites tablettes nos ordinateurs ou
téléphones pour faire signer légende et
porte à porte etc
vous êtes prêts vous y aller à fond
allez voir ça va décoller entre les
ballons de plage et les cagettes de
tomates
un député accompagnée d'un garde du
corps un peu particulier dites lui qu'il
est bien dans son truc comme sandwich
madame ce qu on a hésité on sait pas
s'ils ont gardé la tête haute a
finalement gardé la tête un homme
sandwich bien pratique pour engager la
conversation
dans la torpeur de l'été les français
n'ont pas forcément la tête au rip sur
ce marché de mimizan le député boris
vallot part en quête de signatures est
donc là vous pouvez soutenir le principe
du référendum sur internet
il y en a encore quelques dames en tout
cas pas cette fois ci se donnent la main
sur ce sujet on n'a pas été écoutée dans
le débat parlementaire donc là on
suggère de faire un référendum pour
demander aux français ce qu'ils en
pensent et non et non je vais pas
renoncer et donc on peut empêcher ça
avec le sur internet en soutenant le
référendum pour pouvoir voir un
référendum si vous êtes la serre on en
compte trois de plus mais on est à 3
après on attraperait je pense qu'ils
sont là
oui on a même la possibilité de faire là
si vous avez 5 minutes ou là maintenant
vous devez alors vous passez boris
vallot ne se contente pas de promesses
dans son sillage une militante fait
signer sur une tablette numérique
il suffit d'une carte d'identité il faut
qu'ils aient tous les prénoms tous les
nommer et que ce voyage avait exactement
comme sur la carte électorale alors je
pense que sur la carte électorale
il faut prendre son temps me dicter le
numéro mais avec un peu de patience on
finit par y arriver
votre soutien a bien été par un camp d
une quinzaine de signatures en moins de
deux heures chacun a son opinion sur le
sujet
comme ces toulousains dont l'aéroport a
été vendue à un groupe chinois
toulouse est devenu privé et on n'a pas
trop accepté et on nous a rien demandé
et el tolosa ses fesses étaient sous le
gouvernement précédent est en france il
faut le garder
moi je dis on va pas commencer à rendre
tous nos entreprises et nous nous et
fera structure à des étrangers parce que
quand on aura quoi et on ne pourra plus
gérer ça sera les étrangers qui vont
gérer notre place alors enfin moi je
suis pas d'accord mais on peut vous
avoir le même mais pour femmes
voilà oyonnax qui ont une chance de
baigner et rien d'autre qui transpire
comme des bêtes élevées au regard des
référendum montreront peut décider
vous lirez ça
pour gardois bourbon hommage à la pop
la campagne semblent bien parties en à
peine trois semaines les partisans du
rip vont recueillir 500 mille signatures
mais à la rentrée le soufflé va retomber
et la grève contre les retraites deux
mois de décembre ne va rien arranger
les français ont la tête ailleurs les
signatures se font de plus en plus rare
et la campagne du rip senlis le 13 mars
le verdict tombe à peine plus d'un
million de signatures
on est très loin des 4 millions 700
mille requise
[Musique]
du côté de la majorité on prend acte de
cet échec
je crois que les oppositions avec tous
les outils à leur disposition
elles s'étaient unis dans cette grande
coalition contre la vente la
privatisation des aéroports de paris et
que donc si elle voulait atteindre
l'objectif des 4 millions il fallait
aussi qu'elle fasse davantage campagne
pour l'opposition si la demande de
référendum a échoué
ce n'est pas à cause d'une mauvaise
campagne mais d'un seuil de signature
bien trop élevé je ne crois pas que
un ride pourra atteindre capillon six
cent mille signatures corp était ça ne
marchera pas donc il faut le changer bc
seuil aujourd'hui en théorie plus rien
n'empêche le gouvernement de privatiser
adp mais il ne le fait pas car la
pandémie de coronavirus a cloué les
avions au sol
la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
n'est plus vraiment d'actualité
dans le contexte actuel de la crise du
duc ovide 19
effectivement le secteur de l'aérien est
un secteur qui a été particulièrement
touchée et donc nous avons besoin
d'attendre la reprise économique pour
que les conditions de marché soient
réunies et pouvoir vendre aéroports de
paris dans les meilleures conditions
une privatisation repoussé presque
enterré les partisans du référendum
penses tu y est quand même un peu pour
quelque chose
lorsqu'avec valérie rabault nous avons
lancé à tous les deux cette procédure
nous avions également un objectif
c'était de gagner du temps je vous le
cache pas évidemment nous n'avions pas
prévu évidemment la pandémie la crise du
coc vide à tuer définitivement la
privatisation des aéroports de paris
qu'est ce que je crois tant mieux oui on
a gagné au moins 7 cette bataille-là est
de ton qu'on l'a on la gagne et non pas
seulement parce que la prise du côté des
arrivées mais parce que par notre
bataille nous avons réussi aussi à faire
durer le débat c'est aussi ça qui l'a
permis
pas de référendum et une privatisation
désormais incertaine
cette première tentative de rip n'aura
fait que des perdants
[Musique]
m